Master angel it's so good to see you
again I see you've got some promo in the
background now that it's here we've got
the song plus we've got the music video
how does it feel to have fans be able to
listen to it now it feels absolutely
incredible I've been waiting for this
song for so long and you know I feel
like you see all these different layers
to usher is and to my music you
definitely see the evolution as well but
you know being here getting the right
song is getting put out songs you know
making the visualizer with my family I
mean you know my dad's a location scout
err and my mom's the hairdresser no we
do everything as a family so um it's
been it's been it's been amazing I love
that now let's talk about the visualizer
because you know obviously during this
quarantine time you're you're limited
you can't go out and have a full-blown
production sector music video so when
you and your family sat down to think
about what you wanted this song to look
like in a video the story that you
wanted to tell what was that what were
those conversations like I mean you know
we obviously put out like a bunch of
like concepts and you know we're looking
on Pinterest but I feel like with guilty
it had to be like I wanted it to be
visually stunning it's just like an it's
it's just a piece it's a needs to be a
cinematic piece that's just visually
stunning in you know being on the
mountains and then transitioning onto
the rooftop I feel like that's just the
vibe for the song and really if we
weren't in quarantine that's what I kind
of envisioned it to look like let's talk
about the inspiration behind the song
because I read that you said you know in
fidelity there's these emotional lyrics
of infidelity but it's not something
that you've experienced in your life
thank God so how do you tap into that
song in these lyrics and connect with it
yeah I feel like for me it's trying to
put myself in other people's shoes you
know I haven't like I said before this I
haven't you know experienced any any of
those things so I was trying to write as
if I could put myself in that position
and you know the lyrics just kind of
came naturally and that's
how I look at it you know what I'm
acting you know I'd go on to set and I
had the character but you know I'm
strictly writing from Asher yeah it's
hard to write about something when you
haven't experienced it so you know I do
my best to try and write it and to try
and feel those emotions and mota those
kind of feelings on top of the single
you also have a new fan magazine that is
out you are busy working during cream
where did you get the idea to do this
app well I feel like a lot of my a lot
of my like core fanbase like like they
know a lot about me but you know I have
a lot of followers and some of them
don't know like you know what my life is
like how I started and you know I came
up with the idea with my mom saying
let's make this magazine I mean you have
nothing else to do like we're doing our
thing but you know let's have the fans
like really like I don't know one of
them I don't want why not I'm sure they
want a magazine I mean why not it was
the idea the idea just came to us and
you know there's never before some
photos there's you know fun fact
questions about Asher it's so it's all
Asher I thought the things removed it
something like that supposed smile on
their face is this fan magazine gonna be
something that's recurring or they're
gonna be more issues as you know you
continue in your career yeah yeah I
think it's so cool that I get to you
know share my story and you know share
my journey with the world and you know
hopefully we a make more and that's the
goal yeah this is this is the start and
then the book I still have a day I love
that this fan magazine is also available
in Spanish - I think that's really
special to be able to include a fan base
it's just outside of the US
why was that important for you to make
sure you did I think because I mean most
of my core fan base like I said is you
know Spanish and that what I wanted to
do I wanted to incorporate that because
I feel like you know a lot of people
don't do that like you know I had to
learn a couple of Spanish and you know
that kind of stuff but I just wanted to
be able to connect with my fans and you
know I'm not just there I guess in a way
like he's you know me speak English but
he's so cool freeline Spanish so I
pushed myself to do that and now we put
out a magazine in Spanish English I
think we're the first to ever do it
actually
I think that's true ya know it's insane
it means the world to me I just want to
connect with everyone so what is one
thing that you can tease maybe someone
hasn't purchased the magazine yet you
know T's a little something so that that
gets them to go okay so this is really
cool thing so we had a we had a dream
analyst too much but they had them
analyzed like my dream and like
something I'm like what it means I
haven't seen it yet but I'm super
excited to see that that's sick I've
never even heard of that so I wonder I
tried to explain my dreams best as
possible so let's see what it means I
mean that's pretty cool that we get to
do stuff like that it's different a
dream analyzer what was the dream so the
dream was it was it was it was something
similar to like what's happening like
this global pandemic and man keep
addressing about this now I remember but
I was trying to figure out how to like
you know I guess I get a vaccine for it
or something but it wasn't this it was
something similar to that and you know
everyone had to stand in this line there
was a thousands of people waiting to you
know try and figure it out I don't know
but I can't wait to see what it means
and you know what happened is that the
script first Shazam to go pandemic
Suzanne saves last time I talked to you
obviously you know things have changed
with the sequel and you guys you know I
had to push it back a little bit we
actually did you just talked to Zachary
recently as well I mean have there been
any updates since the last time we got
to talk about it I I mean we are now
shooting in supposedly January and it's
a bit set to come out 2022 but I haven't
read the script yet but what we do know
is we're gonna be very happy with it
it's gonna be big it's gonna be amazing
and I'm pumped can't wait to set woman
have you gotten your invite - Zachary
Levi's Texas ranch yet I called him so
yeah I call I told him not too long ago
I was like bro let me just come up like
all of your quarantine buddy
to get it there but let's just hang out
let's just take this time to like love
one another and spend time with one
another yeah yeah now so now before the
ball was in his court now it's in yours
now now he's extended the invite now you
gotta go you can't wait anymore I can't
I can't blame him anymore
dang it you know a sure some things have
changed a little bit since the last time
we spoke recently just last month
you and Annie LeBlanc have broken up
first and foremost how are you it's been
it's been a hard week it's been very
hard it's been hard for me it's been
hard for my family you know quarantine
has been tough you know I haven't seen
her in 75 days I mean that's not easy on
any kind of relationship and we're young
you know we're teenagers so you know we
were seeing each other like every other
day and all of a sudden you know that's
just taken away from us so that was
super hard and I'm heartbroken you know
I I love her so much she was my she's my
everything you know she is my rock
you know I'm she means the world to me
you know I was trying to be optimistic
about the whole thing and you know think
that she would you know maybe come back
or she just needed some time and space
that's you know my kind of approach to
it cuz it just didn't seem real but you
know as soon as it was announced that's
just where I was just oh I was just
devastated it was if I finally knew that
it was real and like it was actually
happening right I feel like I wanted to
make a post just to show tribute like I
just wanted to make a post saying you
know I love you I'm always here for you
and you're a big part of my life that's
the only thing that I was trying to come
across and say and yeah listen to throw
shade or anything like that to cause any
kind of issues not at all I love them
they're amazing my family loves them
that's just not the kind of people that
we are but I think the most important
thing is I just want her heart to be
happy that's the biggest thing
as long as their hearts happy I'm happy
and I'm always gonna be here for her and
family and I believe she knows there's a
lot of questions surrounding a caption
recently on one of your posts after
Annie had taken to Instagram to announce
your breakup she also went on Instagram
live in a very cheerful discussion kind
of alluding to the fact that your mom
had written that caption she just
completely threw me under the bus
and you guys didn't need to know all of
the details is that true not at all I
posted it the main reason why you know
this whole time I was I don't know I
just didn't think I should I wanted to
post something because I wanted to share
how I was feeling and you know I found
it I found this quote that like really
resonated with me and it was exactly the
way I felt in and I was like should I
post it should I know I I just didn't
know what to do I couldn't think
straight aside just society to post it
you know thinking that you know she
would appreciate it and that it was you
know just a tribute saying I love you
you know making me so happy she says
that this is a normal teenage breakup
but you know there's nothing really
normal about two young you know people
in the spotlight who have these
incredible fan bases that are in masses
I mean millions of followers I mean
people inevitably will choose sides and
you know just looking at your Instagram
account looking at her Instagram account
there's a lot of hate being thrown each
way what message would you want to send
to your fans and to her fans right now
to kind of stop this I mean first and
foremost I think I'm just going to say
you know let's take the time to love one
another and support each other and you
know we don't we don't need the
negativity and hey let's just support
each other in the spirit of comic relief
I will say a heartbreak lens - the best
song so that we get to really take you
know this time to focus on us focus on
so that's the way I'm looking at I'm
excited to get my music out there I mean
we got this magazine launch saying it
Oh music magazine movie like what no I'm
pumped
are there any other projects actually
music movies and much to come I am I'm
so ready to share with everyone but yeah
it all starts right now so
[Music]